So, this is one of the two lectures that I am going to take so today we will see unsupervised
learning in particular clustering of various kinds, flat clustering, hierarchical clustering
and so on and so forth.
And then we will also see the principal component analysis one of the most popular approach
for doing dimensionary reduction when you would like to reduce the number of dimensions
from a very high dimensional data.
So, broadly this is the plan for my lecture today.
So, I start with the clustering problem and clustering is generally known as unsupervised
learning and in the sense that we do not use any super supervised data or label data.
We have unlabeled data and more or less the broad objective of clustering is to figure
out the groups of objects which are similar to each other.
So, while we do so we try to fulfill two objectives, one the objects and the items within a cluster
should be similar that is one thing and then the objects and items from different clusters
should be dissimilar.
So, standing on these two objectives we will see several algorithms for clustering data
points.
Now, there are many examples of clustering or application of clustering which you can
think of.
So, I have taken this particular example just to illustrate the utility of clustering algorithms.
For example, in shard result ranking, shard result clustering for instance when we see
some results in response to your query to a particular shard engine when we see a set
of for example, set of documents, so inside the shard engine there are lot of things actually
going on.
For example, if your question is apples and we do not know whether this is the fruit apple
or this is the for example, the company apple and something like that we are never sure
about it.
So, in a situation like that the best thing that a good shard engines can do is to group
the web pages talking about the similar kind of content and then populate top few pages
with various kinds of content covering wide range of things that possibly can cover all
of the aspects that the query is trying to reflect.
So, for example, few documents could be the apple company, it is talking about apple company,
few documents could be from for instance the apple fruit or something like that.
There are many such applications that one can think of where the clustering is really
used.
In fact, in many popular classification algorithms clustering is typically used as an intermediate
step to reduce some of the data annotation budget often.
So, let us take this particular example for instance, so in this case, for example, we
have this particular data, so for simplicity I have used two dimensional data, it has only
two features and so on so forth.
And so we have a data like this, so what we like to do in this case is to uncover the
underlying structure or rather the clusters of this data.
So, apparently from this particular figure, what we can see is that that this particular
data is showing three clear clusters and so our objective would be to try to figure out
those clusters in an automatic way.
Now, note that we do not have any levels, that means we do not have any ground truth
for this one, we only have the feature vectors or some raw data or something like that and
we have to basically find out the groups automatically using some clustering technique.
So, what are the major issues in clustering and these are very important issues when you
are trying to perform any kind of clustering on any kind of data.
So, the first issue is the representation for clustering, so you can have data with
explicit features, for example, in a tabular form data where the features are already known
to you, you can have a set of images, you can have a set of textual contents or documents,
you can have videos and audios and so on so forth.
So data might come in various forms and therefore, before one is trying to apply any clustering
technique or algorithm, we need to understand how we can represent data, for example, converting
the raw data into a form that a particular clustering algorithm can understand, so which
is called feature engineering.
The second most important issue is basically the similarity or the distance between example.
So, all clustering algorithms will stand on similarity or dissimilarity measure and therefore,
one has to define what kind of similarity or dissimilarity measure we are going to use
to group the objects because they are the backbone of any kind of clustering algorithm.
The second issue that we often encounter is that whether you should do flat clustering
or hierarchical clustering and we will spend some time on this particular aspect later
in this particular lecture, so we will see how these things actually going to happen.
And the final thing is basically that how many clusters we would like to create.
Now whether we fix beforehand that we would like to create certain or 15 clusters from
the data or whether we can figure out from the data itself what would be the appropriate
number of clusters given the raw data.
So these are the three broad things, so the major things that one has to tackle when we
are trying to cluster the data points.
So there are broadly two types of clustering algorithms, one is flat algorithms.
So in this case we usually start with random partitions of the data and then what we do
we refine it iteratively for example, K-means algorithm which are going to see in little
more detail later on is one such example.
So in this case what we finally get is basically a disjoint set of groups.
That means each element or object will belong to exactly one group not more than one and
that is why you are calling flat clustering or partitional clustering often we call it.
Now the second category of algorithms which we call hierarchical algorithms we have brought
the two approaches in there bottom up or agglomerative or top down and divisive.
So in this case unlike the previous case in flat algorithms one particular element might
not belong to multiple clusters and in this case the clusters are typically organized hierarchically
sharing some sort of common relationship.
For example, hockey and cricket could be two different kinds of groups and again we can
group them together in a category called sports.
So hockey and cricket will be belonging to a lower level of category and then when you
mark them together to a bigger group we call sports that is basically you know one level
up in the hierarchy.
So also these are the kinds of things that we do often.
Now another categorization is basically the hard clustering and the soft clustering.
So in hard clustering each example or point belongs to exactly one cluster and in soft
clustering an example can belong to more than one cluster with a membership value.
In the sense that that it will tell whether a particular object or element is in a particular
cluster and to what extent.
So it is like a probabilistic membership for all of these points and it will tell you to
what extent a particular example is part of a particular cluster in your data something
like that we will do.
There are good reasons why we do that sometimes it is actually not possible in reality or
not very practical to assign a particular object to a single cluster we also would like to
know that what this possibility that this particular example is also a member of another
cluster.
So in a situation like that we basically try to apply soft clustering approaches.
Now we study our first flat clustering algorithm called K-means algorithm this is one of the
oldest technique in machine learning and still very widely used for a simplicity, conceptual
simplicity, computational simplicity and also effectiveness.
So as I mentioned it is very efficient, simple and widely used because of a simplicity and
so the main steps of K-means are basically this.
First we start with some initial cluster centers.
So if we for example would like to create 10 cluster from data we start with say K-value
10.
So initially find out using some method that what would be the 10 initial cluster centers.
Then what we do we assign cluster for each member to the closest center which we call
assignment step.
So once we have the centers then for each element we take we figure out which center
is going to the closest to that particular cluster, particular point and then we assign
the point to that particular cluster.
And finally what we do we recalculate the centers as the mean of the points in the cluster
has changed.
So we start with a very weak guess which is often randomly done.
Then we do assignment step and then because we have done assignment steps the initial cluster
centers are not that valid.
So what we do is change it, refine it to find out better cluster centers and so on and so
on.
And we iterate step 2 and step 3.
We do not touch step 1, this is one time job.
So we simply iterate step 2 and step 3 many many times to improve the quality of centers
and correspondingly quality of clusters of the data.
So we need to stop.
So typically we stop using one of these two possibilities.
One we stop after number fixed iteration that is pretty common often we do or we see that
in two successive iterations if the centers or the memberships are not changing then we
can also stop.
So we will see how K-Means actually works with this small example.
We assume that we have these data points which we would like to cluster.
So we say we would like to create three clusters from this data.
So in K-Means you have to specify the number of clusters that you want to create the value
of K because that is a precondition that you have to follow.
So therefore we are going to create three clusters from this data.
So our first step will require that we initialize three centroids and typically we do it randomly
from the original data.
So now say that we have chosen three random points with three different colored boxes
you can say blue, red and pink and so on so forth.
So these are three initial centers that we have chosen randomly from the original data.
Now once we have done that then in step two our objective would be to assign cluster memberships
for each of these data points in my data.
So who will be the blue one, who will be the red one and who will be the pink one.
So that is what we have to basically decide in this case.
So we do that by computing the closest cluster center that we have right now.
So if we go by that rule, what happens is something like this that we have at this assignment.
So the color codes basically tell us that which element is going to be in which cluster.
So the blue ones are closest to the blue square initial centers, the red ones are the red
one and the pinks basically for the pink square initial centers.
Now once we have done this step, the earlier cluster centers that we have done randomly
is no longer valid because you have assigned the cluster memberships and basically we need
to update the cluster centers from what we had in the previous step.
So what we do basically we take some kind of mean of all these elements somewhere in
the middle, the new centers will be lying.
So if we do that which is basically step 3, then we are going to get something like this.
Now we can see the squares are basically the centroids for each of these clusters in this
case.
So that is the first completion of the first iteration of our algorithm.
So now that we have slightly better centroids compared to the random one that we had.
Now we have to iterate step 2 and step 3 repeatedly in order to improve our quality of centroids
and consequently the quality of clusters.
So again in step 2 what we do, we basically again now that we have new centroids that
we again try to compute the cluster memberships for each of these data points, so if we do
that we are going to get something like this.
Some members will change their cluster memberships for sure because you now have different sets
of centroids after updating the original one.
So that is the basically the step 2 in the next iteration.
So now again since because we have new memberships and so on so forth, so what we do again we
have to apply step 3 which is basically readjusting or recomputing the centroids is the mean thing.
So which we do and we are going to get something like this again.
So this is the completion of iteration 2, sorry there is a slight typographical mistake
it should be iteration 2 completion not iteration 1.
So therefore essentially what we have to do we have to basically iterate step 1, step 3
multiple times to improve our cluster quality.
So again we do the same thing we simply find out the cluster memberships for each of the
data points which is step 2 then again readjust the cluster centroids and so on and so forth.
So this is the completion of iteration 3.
So in this way we simply move on until and unless either we basically have reached the
required number of iterations that we set or we see that the centroids are not changing.
So when the centroids are not changing nothing you can gain by doing lot of iterations.
So we know that we are more or less rich to stable solution and so we will stop.
So there is no change so basically we will stop in this case.
So now the question is there are two important questions that we have to address one that
how to assign the cluster in each example to the cluster center and then how to recalculate
the centers.
So you know we have to figure out which one is going to be the closest to which particular
cluster centroid and so on and so forth.
So we do this by using a distance or similarity measure.
So typically we use distance measure one can also use similarity measure no problem.
So what we do basically for each data point we find out the distance between all the centroids
in my data in this case we can see using three different colors because we had three centroids
and the blue one basically the circle blue circle is basically the one which we are considering
okay to try to assign the membership of.
So we figured out the distance between this particular point and three cluster centroids
okay and then like assign this to a centroid which like where you have the minimum distance
okay.
So there are a lot of distance measure that people who can choose or similarity measures
people can choose.
So one of the very common distance measure that we use is called Euclidean distance.
So of course objective given two vectors say n dimensional vectors okay of two points we
simply want to compute the distance between these two points which is like nothing but
a numerical value a number okay telling one number telling how far these two points are
okay.
So you can use because centroid is a vector and a point is also a vector on the same dimension
so you can easily compute this number and so on so forth.
Now I am just taking one example of distance measure there are other distance measures
like Minkowski's distance then you have Manhattan distance then you have Molonov's distance
and so on so forth.
There are a lot of distance measures so depending upon the particular application of the nature
of the data one can use any of this distance measure.
So K means is a general purpose algorithm and it is not the case that Euclidean has
to be used one can use any other things.
So next is basically the recalculating the centers.
Now once you change the cluster membership and so on so forth we have to recalculate
the centers using a certain set of points.
So for example in this case we would like to figure out what would be the central point
for the blue cluster, central point for the red cluster and central point from the purple
the pink cluster.
So these are the three things basically have to figure out because centroid is something
that we will be using to figure out the cluster membership in every iteration.
So essentially we have to figure out these square boxes out of this like this blue, red
and pink data.
So how do we compute that number?
So here is a simple thing essentially you take a set of vectors from a particular cluster
so we are interested in figuring out the centroid for the blue one.
So what we do basically we simply take all the blue points and take the min vector of
that one.
So min vector is nothing but simply we add all these vectors and simply divide by the
number of data points that you have in a particular cluster.
It is a simple addition thing that you can do.
Now these are so far it is a mechanism for doing K-means clustering.
Now actually what are you trying to achieve in this case?
Now because you already have seen quite a bit of machine learning models in this particular
series of lectures.
So one of the key things in any machine learning model is an objective function or loss function
or profit function or whatever you can call it.
We often call it objective function.
So either you maximize it or minimize it something like we have to do.
So in this case also K-means is not like just a plain simple algorithm it is also trying
to minimize a thing called K-means loss.
So K-means loss is nothing but so value which will indicate the quality of clusters that
you have generated.
So the expression in this case what you can see is something like this that we take every
data point in this case this is Xi.
We take the cluster center closest to the data point Xi which is like basically the
mu K in this case and we find out the distance between the data point and the closest cluster
center and simply add them up for all the data points.
So essentially what this is telling you is basically that to what extent the data points
are to what extent the data points are dissimilar to or similar to the cluster centers in which
it belongs.
So if the loss value is very high then naturally you know the data points which are belonging
to a particular cluster are far apart from the centroids in this case you can expect
that the clusters are basically dispersed.
If it is small then you know the clusters are actually very compact so that is the physical
intuition or the explanation behind this particular loss function.
So K-means function the K-means algorithm that we have seen so far it attempts to minimize
this loss value as much as possible but of course like all difficult problems, clustering
problems is also controversial very challenging so there is no guarantee that you are going
to get the optimal loss value in this case but you can get somewhat good value depending
upon how you are starting up with and so on and so forth.
Now I started up with by saying that K-means is a very fast algorithm very efficient algorithm
and so we like to see little bit of mathematical analysis of the computational budget for the
K-means algorithm.
So in order to understand that we try to understand the computational overhead in every step of
this iteration.
So one step is basically the assignment step where we are trying to figure out the closest
cluster center for a particular point.
So if you have K centers and N data points then a single pass for every data point we
have to compute the distance between all the K centers so in that case the complexity is
going to be order of KN and then in the next step we will have to compute, recalculate the
cluster center which is nothing but a linear term algorithm.
So this is a computational budget for one particular iteration.
Now if you repeat these steps many many times we often do for example say P times or so
on and so forth then you simply multiply P into with this particular numbers.
So that is basically the complexity of this K-means algorithm.
But to give you sort of the final verdict on this one K-means is generally a linear time
algorithm assuming that the dimension of this data is basically not so high so under the
assumption it is typically a linear time algorithm and therefore it is extremely fast.
Now there are few important issues, practical issues rather which we have to deal with.
So fast issue is basically the number of clusters that we would like to create.
So you have to tell K-means algorithm that this many clusters I would like to create.
So how to do that?
Second issue the convergence issue that means when we are going to stop this algorithm and
the third issue perhaps one of the most important issue is basically the initial cluster center
selection, how we are going to select the initial cluster centers so that we do not
create bad quality clusters.
So these three things we need to now address and we will see one by one how we can address
these three important things.
So first let us look at how we choose the value of K or at least an attempt to choose
value of K in a systematic way because we never know from our original data that how
many clusters are there and if the data is high dimensional this is even more difficult
to figure out visually that this many clusters are there.
So therefore we need to have some systematic way of figuring out the value of K.
So one popular approach that people follow is called elbow method.
So in this particular method what we do is something like this.
So we have a data then we run K-means with different K-values starting from 2 for example
to a very high value say 100.
So for every K-value you run the K-means algorithm and it will produce the corresponding K-means
loss which we discussed earlier.
So loss is going to tell you to some extent the quality of clusters that you have generated.
So you simply plot a graph like this the x axis is the K in the number of clusters that
you produced and y axis is the loss value that you also produced from this particular
clustering.
So now what we do we basically plot this graph and we try to look at if there is any clear
pattern in this particular graph.
So if you see that the graph is showing a elbow like structure a bending at elbow that
means it is basically you know dropping at a very high rate and then suddenly it gets
flattened okay it becomes very flat.
So if you have observed such a pattern like this then possibly the point where you see
that the value dropped very abruptly and then flattened so this is the point to be chosen
as a number of clusters.
So in this case for example the good value could be 3 in this case.
Now while I am saying this this is a very well known technique and therefore I must
give you a small warning is that that this is sort of a guideline not necessarily a full
group method okay it does not guarantee that if you apply this technique you are going
to find out the right number of clusters okay so this is not the case always.
It can give you some kind of guideline but it does not guarantee that this particular
key value is going to be the optimal one okay.
So therefore this has to be used very very carefully.
The second approach that we use is called shield weight measure.
So the key idea for good clustering which I mentioned at the very beginning is this
that the value has to be small within cluster variance has to be small okay that means the
points which are belonging to a particular cluster it is going to be very small and then
the between cluster variance has to be very large because that is basically a two broad
criteria that we try to fulfill in any clustering algorithm.
So we will be standing on these two criteria to use another measure to try to figure out
a reasonably good value of k.
So in this particular case we use within cluster measure which is nothing but a measure which
tells you to what extent the clusters are compact.
So if you can look at this particular expression the C i is the cluster for data point i, D
ij is nothing but the distance between i and j.
So you take all pairs of data points in a particular cluster okay and then compute their
distances you take some sort of average distance between them and so on so forth okay.
So essentially this is telling intuitively that what is the average pair wise distance
of points those who are belonging to a particular cluster okay.
So this will to some extent reflect the compactness or closeness of a particular cluster.
Now the next important criterion is basically between cluster variance.
So in this case we take data points from different clusters from the same cluster.
So if you look at this in this case is basically we take data points from different clusters
and compute the distance between the different points and so on so forth.
And then we use this to quantities to compute the silhouettes measure which is nothing but
a measure telling to what extent the cluster quality is good or bad.
Now so this measure again once again will be used to kind of plot a graph and then try
to figure out what would be the good reasonably good value of K okay.
So in this case unlike the K means loss value higher score is actually better.
So if you get higher score for a particular K value for silhouettes measure that means
the cluster quality is good.
So once again similar to the previous approach what we do we run this algorithm K means algorithm
for different K many many times started from 2 to say for example 100 or 200 depending
upon your data and then again we plot the K versus the silver score x axis is K y axis
is the silver score and we look at the graph and we see a pattern something like this.
So what you can see in this case is that the value initially was very small slowly increasing
then it started decreasing suddenly okay so you can think about something like this basically
the angle that you can see okay smaller the angle sharper the changes and so on so forth.
So the moment you see something like that increasing and then suddenly started decreasing
then this is the point which can reflect that the number of clusters is good one.
So in this case also the value could be 3 is a good number of clusters once again just
like the previous case this is not a guarantee that this value will actually reflect what
is the optimal number of clusters that is often a tricky thing we never know optimal
number of clusters before and because this is an unsupervised learning things become
even more difficult because we are dealing with high dimensional data so you can never
plot this one on a real like a figure which a human can understand.
So while you can use these things as a guideline to figure out what would be the possible good
values of K it has to be used also the other factors like the quality of results that you
are finally getting by using this clustering techniques and so on so forth.
Now the another important issue is basically the initial cluster center or we often call
it seed selection so remember that the first step of K-minus clustering algorithm is basically
the seed selection approach so in seed selection what we try to do we try to figure out what
would be the good number of centers sorry good centers that we will use to start with.
So if the centers are bad then you know we are going to get very bad quality clusters
so we will see strategies of figuring out the goods androids in this particular case.
So we see in this case that we initially like chose the centers randomly okay so now let
us see what happens the consequences of random center selection okay now say my original
data from my original data I selected the centers randomly so if I do that what will
happen so this is going to get something like this once you find out the cluster memberships
for all the data points okay now certainly if you look at this figure carefully this
is not the desired clusters that the data is reflecting okay the clusters are actually
elsewhere okay but the data is actually reflecting something for example possibly the good clusters
should be something like this so this one and this one and this one okay so this is
the possible like the desirable clusters that one can expect from this particular data but
because of the poor choice of the centroids selection of the centroids randomly we ended
up getting a cluster which are of very bad quality.
So this particular cluster that I have got actually from the pink initial centers is
very dispersed elongated cluster certainly we are not saying that this is a good cluster
and this is one of the most critical issues in Kevin's clustering how to choose the centers
initially and you know good centers initially.
So we will be spending some time on this particular aspect and see what we can do to tackle this
particular problem.
So some of the consequences of this initial center something like that you can have slow
convergence that means it can take a lot of time to reach to a point where you can see
that you know my clusters are good or you converge to a suboptimal clustering that means
the quality of cluster is actually very bad that means the clusters are dispersed okay.
So to tackle this problem in literature you have a load of common heuristics that people
generally adopt okay.
So we do random centers in the space, we randomly pick from the future vectors, we choose points
least similar to existing centers and so on and so forth or we try to find out multiple
starting points something like that.
So these are some common heuristics that people often use.
So one of the very popular heuristics that people use is the furthest centers heuristics.
So in this case intuitively we attempt to make sure that the centers that we are choosing
initially are far apart.
So they are like very dispersed from one another that is the basic intuition behind this particular
approach.
So how it works?
So first point you choose randomly because there is no other option that you can make
use of which we call first center then for the remaining points we find out that which
point is furthest from the existing point that we have already chosen okay.
The one which has the highest distance from the existing points will choose that as a
potential centroid and you simply move on like that one.
So objective is to make sure that the points which are far apart in the original data will
be chosen as possible possibly good initial centroids but it has its own problem.
So for example in this case say k is equals to 3 so what we do in this case?
So pick a random point from the first center something like that then we basically choose
the next point something like that okay because this is furthest from this particular point
and so on so forth.
So in this way simply you proceed okay something like that we will do.
So if your data is showing good structure then possibly this approach is a reasonably
good solution to tackle the initial cluster centroid selection problem but you know in
a real life data you do not expect the data to be good and therefore it has its own problems
which you will see in the next slide.
So let us look at this particular data okay so clearly from this particular data what we
see is that the data has at least 3 outliers in the sense that somehow it is noisy data
they are very far apart from the other data points and so on so forth.
So now say we have decided to apply the furthest center heuristic to figure out say 4 cluster
centroids from this data what will happen?
Now as I mentioned that the first center has to be chosen randomly so for example you chose
the spring point.
Now next point we will choose which is very very far apart from this particular point.
So it could be something like this one so this point because this particular point is
like furthest apart from the point that we have already chosen something like this.
Now once we have that these two points the third point that we will choose is basically
very far apart from both these two points because we have already chosen these two points.
So this is going to be something like this then the next point is basically far apart
from all the three points that we have already chosen so it could be something like this.
Now the obvious problem that we can see in this case is that it will end up choosing
often the outliers in the data because it does not have any idea whether this particular
point is outlier or not and as a result we end up choosing this point.
Similarly this is not going to give good clusters.
So now based on this initial centroids if you cluster the whole thing four clusters
you are going to create then what you get is something like this the entire thing is
going to be in one cluster this one is going to be in another cluster singleton point singleton
cluster this is in one cluster and this is in one cluster.
So this is most likely situation the end result of k-means in this particular case.
Now certainly this is not a good clustering in this particular data.
So we will see how we can address these issues with another approach.
So a better approach of doing these things is called k-means plus plus once again this
is a simple approach simple modification to the standard k-means and it tries to address
this problem that we mentioned little while ago.
So I would like to emphasize before I start this one is that this approach only deals
with the initial centroid selection it does not change anything in the clustering.
So it will simply see that how the initial centroids are going to be good and then we
will simply select that.
So this is a probabilistic approach in this case unlike the previous case and we will
use a probabilistic approach to select the centroids in this case and as I mentioned
the other steps are exactly same with the k-means algorithm there is no change only the step
one will be changed in this case.
So let us look at this approach carefully.
So what we do that the first center say we are interested in choosing the k-centers we
just would like to compute the k-centers ok that is the objective.
So the first center that we choose we choose randomly from this data because we have no
other option we simply choose randomly from the data say we call it C1 the first center
that we choose.
Now from the next center onwards we will apply the probabilistic approach to figure out the
other k-1 centroids.
So what we do basically now for each data point in my data set ok my data set is basically
x capital X all the data points I will compute a distance called dx you can use Euclidean
distance ok.
So the value called dx and dx is the distance of x from the closest center we already have
chosen ok and once you have that then what we will do we will select the data point x
from x as a new center with a probability value this one.
Because we already have dx for this particular point we already have all these values here
and so on so forth.
So you can simply compute this probability value and we are going to choose this probabilistically
ok that is how basically we are going to select this particular data a particular data point
and then you repeat step 2 and step 3 until you get the k centers ok.
So the first center is chosen randomly we only randomly then the remaining centers are
chosen probabilistically using the distance measure.
Now you might be wondering how this particular expression is going to tackle the problem
that we mentioned.
Now to some extent this approach encodes or implements the farthest center heuristics.
Now the probability value of this one that x will be chosen as a centroid for example
a centroid is actually higher more or less proportional to the dx value ok it means that
if the dx value is very high then the probability also is going to be very high.
And what does dx denote?
It denotes the distance from the closest centroid that we already have if the distance
is high then you expect that the point is very far apart from the existing centroids.
There is more or less the farthest center heuristics but with a probabilistic twist
it is not deterministic it is a probabilistic approach.
So you see now with a little small little illustration of this one.
So we would like to create three clusters from this data that means we have to choose
three initial centroids.
So say the first centroid is something like this one because this will be chosen randomly
we have no other information so this is our first centroid ok this particular point.
Now we are going to choose the next point for this particular clustering.
So the most likely second center could be this one I am not saying the second centers
I am saying most likely second center there is a distinction between second center and
the most likely center because this is a probabilistic approach and the distance between the center
which already have chosen and the other points all other points if you take all other points.
So this point has the highest distance among all other points ok there you do not find
any other point in this particular data which has higher distance than this particular point.
So this will have the most likely chance of getting selected as a second centroid.
So because of distance so on so forth now that we have chosen these two centroids for example
assuming that the first centroid is this one this is the first one this is the second one
and so on.
Now while we are going to choose the third point we will see that for every point which
one is the closest centroid because you have to figure out the dx value ok.
If you for example considering the point x we have to figure out the dx value.
So how do we compute the dx value for in this case the dx value in this case is basically
this one ok because we have to make sure that the point that we are choosing is not very
close to any existing centroids that we have already chosen and therefore we have to we
have to basically use the center which is closest to the point that we are considering
ok.
So that basically the dx value is nothing but the minimum distance among all the centroids
that we already have.
Now if you simply apply this one then the most likely centroid's third centroid in
this case is going to be something like this one ok.
So this way we can tackle the problem of selecting centroids which are very close to each other
using this probabilistic approach and we call this K-means++ approach which only focuses
on the selection of the initial centroids from the data.
So this more or less concludes the flat clustering or K-means clustering and we will move on
to the next part of by lecture.
So in my next part I will focus on the clustering graph or native operator.
Now let me set the background first.
Now in K-means it is a flat clustering so it is nothing but basically in a one particular
point we will belong to exactly one cluster and also the data that we are dealing with
is basically a fixed dimensional data you have say n number of features and so on and
so forth.
In this case we will deal with slightly different kind of clustering technique.
I have two major purposes one is to introduce technique on graph data and also to tell you
hierarchical clustering as well.
So we talked about the n dimensional point clustering things in K-means.
So what about the following things for example you would like to cluster the Facebook friendship
network.
We have individuals in the group and there are friends and not friends and we would like
to find out the communities or groups which are like friends among themselves very close
connections between them and so on so forth or for example we like to find out the communities
in question answering website like Cora so that we know which community is on machine
learning which community is on NLP and something like that.
In protein interaction network for instance we have lot of proteins that we know and they
are responsible for many kinds of things for disease and so on so forth.
So how they interact with each other how you can group the proteins so that we know that
these groups of proteins are responsible for a particular disease so that we can treat
it or we can design a new drug or medicine or something like that.
So these are like wide variety of applications where we have to deal with a different sorts
of data called network data.
So take this example for instance we have these little like black dots and their connections
you know the dots are individuals and the connections the lines are telling the connection
between them and so on so forth okay.
So if you look at this data very carefully it is actually reflecting several clusters
of groups you know visually.
So our objective would be given a data like this you like to figure out the possible groups
in this particular data okay.
So once again this is a clustering problem but on a different kind of data.
So I quickly introduce most of you have possibly the background knowledge of the graph and
so on so forth.
So I quickly introduce a graph and then I will move on to the particular clustering
algorithm.
So as you know the graph is composed of two things a set of objects which are often called
nodes and a set of connections are called edges and so if you take for example this
one we have four nodes A, B, C and D and then we have four connections connecting A,
B, C, C, D and B, D.
So the nodes are individuals and the connections are telling some sort of you know similarity
for example if you consider Facebook friendship network then the nodes are individuals and
the connection is telling that whether A is friend of B or something like that.
So there are possible various kinds of graphs you have unweighted graph where the connections
do not have any weight and the weighted graphs where the connections are weights for example
the road network you know how far one city is from the other one something like that okay.
So graph data shows relationship between object pairs so that is the kind of setup that we
will be standing on okay and therefore centroid is often not valid in a graph.
So what does centroid mean in your Facebook friendship network okay so it is difficult
to come up with a centroid because there is no central thing in this case okay.
So therefore in order to tackle this one we will see several algorithms for clustering
graph data.
First such algorithm that we will see is clustering unweighted graph okay and then we move on
to the weighted graph.
So there are many algorithms that we know I am going to talk about one very efficient
and simple algorithm on graph.
So this is based on minimum cut or we often call it mean cut okay.
So it works like this for example you have this particular graph involving there are
8 nodes and several edges.
So mean cut of a graph is nothing but a partition of this graph into 2 groups so that the number
of connection and edges crossing between 2 groups that you get are actually minimized.
What essentially like to minimize once you split the group into 2 then you like to see
that the groups have minimum number of connections or edges between them okay so that is how
basically we are going to do that.
Now take for example in this case so this is one possible mean cut partition of this
particular graph.
If you split this graph into 2 parts then you see that there are only 2 connections between
these 2 groups A, B, E, F, 1 group, C, D, G, H another group and there are only 2 connections
between these 2 groups from the original data.
So therefore our objective is to try to figure out such a cut which will minimize this connection
between these 2 groups so in this case a mean cut value is 2.
So the typical approach that people follow for graph clustering using minimum cut is
this that you use a minimum cut algorithm to break graphs into 2 sets because that is
how it is done.
If you like to find out more groups then you take the smaller groups then apply the mean
cut again on the smaller groups break this entire thing into 2 and it simply continue
until the stopping condition is satisfied.
So that is the general principle of mean cut algorithm when we apply on graph data to find
out the graph clusters.
Now this particular technique that I am going to talk about is a simple technique you know
it stands on this following principle.
So what we do we simply repeat until we have 2 nodes because we like to split a particular
graph into 2 parts so that is why basically we will be considering 2 nodes.
So in the very first step we will choose an age at random a particular connection you
choose at random and then it collapse these 2 end points into single nodes put them together
that means choose an age so we know that the 2 end points or the nodes are connected with
each other so therefore we are going to collapse them together put them together.
So for example in this case now look at this particular example carefully and they understand
how it basically happens.
So text for example in this case this is the original graph.
So there are 14 ages in this particular graph.
So the probability that we are going to choose a particular age for example BF in this case
so this particular age is going to be 1 by 14 okay because there are 14 age and there
are basically you can choose one of them so all the ages we will have the same probability
of choosing these things.
Now because this is a probabilistic algorithm you will have to use some random number generator
from your standard library CC plus plus Java or Python you use that and say we choose this
particular age called BF you can choose any other age depending upon the probability value
given by your model or given by your implementation but for this particular demo we assume that
the age that we have chosen is basically BF.
Now once you have chosen that then what we do contraction so by contraction what we mean
is that that we have to put these two end points of this age together in a single group.
Now because the B and F were the two end points of this particular age that we had chosen
so we will put them together in a new group called BF but that is not the end of the story
we have to adjust the connections as well.
Now you look at this thing these two things carefully we now have the parallel ages that
means there are multiple ages between two nodes why this is happening in the original
graph there was an age between A and B so that is why there is one more age okay and
A and F also so I have to maintain the relationship in the new graph that is why you can see there
are two ages between A and BF similarly you see there are two connections between E and
BF but the same logic we have the connection from E to B and E to F and that is the reason
we simply put them together.
So therefore after fast contraction we get something like this one now we again have
to apply the age selection followed by the contraction again so now say for example that
we chose a particular age say gh with probability 1 by 13 okay something like this we have.
Now again we contract readjust this ages and so on so forth so we simply do something like
this one so we put them together g and h we adjusted the number of connections accordingly
and so on so forth okay.
Now again we choose a particular age randomly for example in this case we have chosen dg
and h for instance now the probability of choosing this particular age dg and h is nothing
but 2 by 12 simply because there are two parallel ages in this and there are total number of
ages is actually 12 so that is the probability value.
Now if you chose that then we contract these two together and we are going to get something
like this one because now that we have dg and h together in a single group okay and we
now have parallel edges accordingly because initially we had two edges between gh and
d okay and also one two edges between gh and c so we simply put them together okay.
Now we repeat the same process we select for example the age ae with probability 1 by 10
and then we contract once again to get something like this one ae and bf.
In the next step what we do we choose say for example an age ae and bf with probability
4 by 9 because there are four connections between ae and bf and there are nine edges
in this current graph so the probability will be 4 by 9 so we do that and then we put them
together ae and bf so we are going to get something like this one okay.
Now we have three nodes still we have to do something because we will stop when we have
two nodes so we continue say we choose now say cdg and h is already 3 by 5 because there
are three edges between c and dgh so we will do that and then we contract these things
together and so on and so forth.
Now at this point we have two nodes a, b, e, f and cdgh and it is time to stop because
this is stopping criterion for this particular algorithm.
So now we basically will stop in this case so here the mean cut value okay is basically
2 okay because the number of edges that we have right now between these two groups is
basically 2 okay so mean cut value is 2 sorry the cut value is to not really mean cut it
could be mean cut or it may not be mean cut but the cut value is actually 2 in this case
but fortunately in this particular case we found out the mean cut value for this particular
graph.
So after doing this one so what now we basically have done is basically we find out one group
called a, b, e, f and then we find out another group called cdgh so therefore it partitions
this graph into two groups with a, b, e, f in one group and cdgh in another group.
So that is how basically it works now if you would like to partition this graph even more
then you take a, b, e, f stuff and then basically apply the same thing again and again okay
and split it off into two groups and simply proceed.
So this is a randomized algorithm and therefore you have to consider this important thing.
Okay, so for good result this is always recommended.
So you run this algorithm multiple times this called Carger's algorithm and therefore
you will going to get multiple cuts for this situation and you take the cut with a minimum
value okay that will tell you the minimum value for this particular cut.
Okay the next topic that we will discuss is clustering weighted graph.
So in this case broadly we have two possible approaches one is called agglomerative approach
or the bottom-up approach another is called divisive approach top-down approach okay.
So in bottom-up we do start with that each object is going to be in single cluster and
then you gradually merge them together and simply form bigger clusters.
In divisive approach we take exactly opposite route we start with all objects in the same
cluster and then we simply split into smaller one something like that we have seen in the
previous case.
But for this particular lecture I am not going to talk about divisive approach I am going
to talk about agglomerative approach and we will see how you can do clustering using
this one.
So in this case we do not require the number of clusters to be fixed a priori in advance
because this is hierarchical clustering in order to terminate you can actually set some
threshold when to stop that is one possible approach that you can use to stop the algorithm.
So I am going to skip this slide also okay.
So in this case what happens is basically something like this.
So we have to define a similarity function that is the foundation for any clustering algorithm
which will tell the similarity between two instances or two clusters and so on so forth.
So first we will start with all instances in the separate cluster say each example will
be in a separate cluster and then we repeatedly join them and so on so forth and how we are
going to join them okay the history of joining okay is basically nothing but recall is dendogram.
So in this case for instance so the initial level of points is something like that.
So first we basically join these two points together and this picture will tell that these
two points are joined together okay.
So first level these, these and these okay something like that and so on okay so all
these dendogram all these figures basically telling that they are the first level joining
merging.
Then when I am basically merging these three things together entire three things then if
you look at this particular dendogram it is telling actually how these two things are
merged.
So dendogram basically dendograms are telling you that how you have merged all the data points
to create bigger and bigger clusters starting from the single points okay.
So the important question is how do you determine the nearness of clusters?
That is a key question that we have to address in hierarchical clustering okay and we will
see with several examples in this case.
So the first one so there are three different things one is basically called the single
link approach where the distance of between, distance between the clusters or points we
choose basically the closest point based on the closest points.
Then we have another approach called complete link where the farthest points are used to
compute the distance and then we have the average link when you take the average distance
between pairs of elements of two clusters and so on so forth okay.
So we will see these things actually with small examples in the next few slides okay.
Now this is the formal definition of the single link agglomerative clustering algorithm or
the approach in which you can basically form the clusters.
So say we have two clusters cluster one and cluster two with several points in each clusters
and we like to find out the similarity between two clusters.
So that is the key point in hierarchical clustering given two clusters how do we compute the similarity
of two clusters okay that is what we do.
Now if you look at the definition carefully this is basically telling the maximum similarity
between two points among all pairs of points.
You take all pairs of points between two groups okay and then simply see what is the maximum
similarity between all pairs of points among all pairs in a particular two groups okay.
So in this case if you look at this example carefully so this number is actually telling
the similarity between different pairs of objects among two groups.
I am not going to compute the similarity within group because we are interested in between
group thing.
So this numbers are telling basically for example 10 is telling the similarity between
two elements this and this something like that okay so now if you apply this thing here
so distance between cluster one cluster two actually three in this case right.
So if you go by for example the similarity you have to take the maximum value if you
go by the distance you have to take the minimum value okay that is basically the definition
of this one.
So in this case if so this number for example if sorry I made a little mistake topographical
mistake here in this case so these values for example the distance is not the similarity
okay.
So if you take that for instance the distance between cluster one and two is basically three
and in this case because that is the smallest distance that we have in this case so the
maximum similarity that we can think about it okay.
So when you compute this similarity or distance between these two groups or these two clusters
we will have to choose the points which have like the smallest distance or highest similarity
they are interchangeable so we will do that.
Now in a similar fashion but with slightly different modification so in this case for
instance when we run this entire thing in single linkage clustering algorithm so say
these are the points.
So initially we start with all points in separate clusters and then we gradually merge.
So how do we merge in this case?
So first merging will be done based on these two points first these two points will be
merged because they are closest to one another.
Next we will basically merge these two points okay.
Next we will merge these two points.
Next we will merge these two points okay.
Now we have slightly bigger clusters and so on so forth.
Now question is next which two clusters will be merged in this case?
Now if you choose this particular cluster and this particular cluster the similarity
between them will be defined by in this case or distance is based on these two points okay
something like that will be done.
Now if you choose this particular cluster or this particular cluster the similarity between
them will be defined by these two points or distance something like that.
So now we have to use this information to compute the distances between the pairs of
clusters in this case and then merge the two clusters having smallest distance or largest
similarity something like that we have to do.
So if you go by this apparently for example if you look at this figures carefully for
instance okay then what you can figure out is that the possibly that these two clusters
need to be merged in the next step okay.
So in this way we simply proceed we merge the clusters one after another and simply proceed
hierarchically and as you know the history of merging the way that basically we are building
the circles will tell you that how they have merged from smaller to bigger which is equivalent
to the dendrogram that we have seen.
Now the problem the biggest problem with the single linkage algorithm is this that you end
up getting the chain or elongated clusters okay why this is the case you take this example
okay.
So if you apply this single linkage algorithm then first you are going to merge these two
points together then you do this merging okay then what you do you do this merging okay.
So essentially you are going to merge all the points together.
So the reason is that that the similarity is defined by the most similar points it does
not really consider the similarity between other points in my group okay if two points
are accidentally very similar to each other okay in two groups then they will dictate
the cluster formation strategy which is pretty bad and you are going to get elongated clusters
often on a real data okay.
Now the difficulty in this case is that that you put them together all four put them together
but a quick inspection will tell you that certainly these two points are very very far
apart they are very dissimilar and yet you put them together because this point and this
point actually these two points are very close to each other okay.
So this is a problem with this particular approach.
Now a possible solution to this one which is once again very widely used is called complete
linkage clustering okay so in this case what we do we just modify how we compute the similarity
between two clusters in this case.
Now you look at carefully the modification to this one in the earlier case we had the
max of similarity okay so we used to take the similarity between two groups based on
the maximum similarity of elements pairs elements in this case we take the minimum similarity
okay when you compute the similarity value between two clusters we will look at who are
the most dissimilar points in my two groups and I use that value as a measure of similarity
okay.
So in this case for example we go by the distance value in this case I am basically using the
distance value not similarity value in this case the similarity between these two clusters
basically 10 as opposed to 3 in my previous case because in this case these two points
this particular point and this particular point they have similarity the distance value
is actually 10 okay.
So because they are farthest like apart among all possible pairs in this case this number
will tell you that how compact the points are into these two particular clusters.
So we will use these values to form the clusters gradually one after another.
So now the question is why we are doing that there is a good reason why we are doing that
for example I have a data point somewhere here in this particular case okay.
Now if you look at this figure carefully then what will happen is that this particular cluster
is basically dispersed not very compact.
Now under the reception the distance between these two clusters is going to be this basically
this one okay which is basically high value.
So automatically this measure will reflect that these two clusters actually far apart
because there is a point belonging to a particular cluster which is actually very far apart from
the other points in the cluster not very compact okay.
So as a result it will tell that okay possibly the clusters are of not good quality and the
numbers will reflect that okay but there is a problem upwards with this approach if there
is one point which is basically very far apart from all others it can also dismantle the
score okay but again these are pros and cons of each and every approach that we deal with
so nothing we can do.
So therefore it makes very tight spherical clusters now in a situation like this one.
So this is an illustration of this algorithm very similar to this one.
So for example initially what we do once again we form the clusters no problem with this approach
again we will do this so on so forth so on so forth okay no change in this case.
Now next time when we form clusters like you know merging by merging and so on so forth
when I compute similarity between this cluster and this cluster these two clusters it will
be determined by these two points okay unlike the single leakage clustering algorithm okay.
For this cluster and this cluster it will be determined by these two points okay something
like that so on so forth and of course for these two clusters this one and this one okay
it will possibly be determined by these two points and so on so forth.
So we will compute all pairs of such similarities and then we will merge the clusters so in
this case possibly if you consider this among all the possible cases in this case also possibly
something like this one.
So we will see so this particular line is the minimum among all okay so we will now
merge these two clusters together to form a bigger cluster okay so in this way you simply
move on to compute the bigger clusters from the smaller ones and so on so forth.
I take one very concrete example to illustrate this point now actually when you write program
or implement the entire thing you have to deal with a graph like structure and a graph
structure is actually represented a computer using a matrix okay so typically you have
a symmetric matrix symmetric like this matrix that basically you take.
So if you take this example carefully for instance that say I have a matrix where I
have 5 objects initially okay I have the 5 objects that I have and I have the similarity
values between distance values between them and so on so forth.
So this value will tell the distance between 2 and 1 okay object 2 and 1 okay or for example
this value will tell the distance between object 5 and 4 okay so for all pairs of objects
you have the distance values which we can represent or we can basically put in a matrix
and then we will basically see how you can apply single liquid algorithm to create the
clusters gradually.
Now in this case what you see is basically the first we will merge so we will choose
the pair among all pairs which are having the minimum distance in this case and then
we simply merge.
So if you look at this very very carefully the minimum distance among all pairs is basically
2 so we basically merge 1 and 2 together in this figure you can see.
Next if we do that then we are going to get something like this we have readjust this
entire thing so we will have to basically recompute the cluster similarity values because
now we put together 1 and 2 together so we readjust these values now we have a matrix
something like this based on the single linkage similarity measure so we will compute these
values and I have shown here the actual values.
So now if you look at these then you have to choose again the minimum distance among
all possible pairs of clusters and we simply put them together so we will do something
like this one okay then once again we readjust this entire thing compute similarity based
on single linkage measure again choose the minimum one we are going to get something
like this one so this is the way we are going to merge the cluster gradually starting from
the single linkage clusters that we had.
Now we look at the complete linkage clusters okay for the same data that we have here okay
and we see what happens the same distance matrix that I have in this case and I will
see what happens in this case so oh sorry so in this case what we can do basically so
right now I have say 1, 2, 3, 4 and 5 okay I have this one now of course the distances
initial distances are given here okay so no problem with this one in the very first step
so we will choose two clusters having minimum distance and simply merge them together so
as you know the minimum value in this case is actually 2 okay so we will merge one and
two together okay so this basically we will merge now because now we have put one and
two together so this is one cluster say this is say cluster 1 this is cluster 2 this is
cluster 3 and this is cluster 4 so now I have to compute the similarity between cluster
1 and cluster 2 for example in this case okay so how do I compute the similarity between
cluster C1 and C2 in this case C1 has two points and C2 has three points now for the
distance rather you can think about it so now the similarity between or the distance
between now the distance between so distance between this for example this two group in
this case now say because this is matrix so in this case the distance between C1, C2
is going to be something like this look at the distance between 1 and 3 because we are
going to compute the distance between C1 and C2 so distance between 1 and 3 is 6 so I am
putting star just to discriminate and then distance between 2 and 3 is 3 in this case
okay so because this is the two distance value that I can make use of and so on so forth.
Now by definition in complicated clustering algorithm I have to choose the farthest points
from between two groups so in this case the higher value is basically 6 so the distance
is going to be 6 in this case okay it will tell you the compactness so in this way simply
we compute this value and so on so forth now the distance between C1 and C2 is 6 between
C2 and C3 between 3 and 4 is basically 4 and 3 is 7 okay and between 4 and 5 the other
values and so on so forth so I have to basically choose the minimum one and simply merge them
together.
So the key thing in this case is basically choosing or the computing the distance values
once we merge two clusters together using the complicated clustering algorithm.
Now the last part of my talk is called principal comfort analysis or PCA in short often we
call it PCA and this is slightly different from what we have talked so far.
So objective here is not to do any clustering but rather reduction of the dimension of this
data that we are dealing with okay and it basically deals with high dimensional data
and we use these linear algebra stuff like eigenvalues and eigenvectors to figure out
what would be the good like sort of reduced features that we can get out of the original
data.
So simply to put it like simply the data reduction objective is basically something like this
that we have a data matrix like this we have say n objects and we have say p variables
or rather p features that we have in my data.
So this is the original matrix that I have and then I will convert this data or rather
transform this data to a reduced form where I have the same number of objects but the
number of variables that I have is basically much smaller compared to p.
So k is generally smaller to p that is kind of the assumption that we will be dealing
with.
So essentially for example if I had original data where I had 1000 features for every object
I will convert every object to say for example 10 features only and these are the wide applications
because it reduces like noise, this reduces unnecessary redundancy in the data, this reduces
the computational complexity because we have to compute similarity between objects and
so on so forth.
So the key questions that we address basically this first question that we asked ourselves
that do we need all vectors like all data for example all n dimensional space to view
the data that is the first question.
Sometimes there are correlated data which we do not need.
So then we have to basically find out the better axis than the original axis.
If I original axis I have something we have something then can we find out better axis
to represent this data.
Then how do I find out the best low dimensional space that conveys the maximum useful information
that I had in the original data?
So to answer all these questions we generally use a thing called principal components.
Now I must say that this is not always applicable for certain kind of data this is not applicable
but for many data the principal components do very good work and we will see when they
can do good work, when they do not do good work.
So let us look at this particular figure carefully ok.
So let us we have this kind of data for example.
If we have this data so this is we are calling the principal component 1.
So principal component is nothing but a line along which the data has maximum variability
ok.
So if you look at this data very carefully this is the line along which the data has
maximum variability.
You do not find any other line along which the data has maximum variability.
The second principal component once we have the principal component 1 the second principal
component that we have is basically this one the red one which will always be perpendicular
to the first principal component ok.
And it will basically give you the residual variance so maximum variance to the second
variance and so on so forth and this is the way simply we will proceed.
The question is how do we figure this out all these lines the good lines from the data
that will tell us the amount of variance and all sorts of stuff.
So the goal in this case is this that I have the original data I will compute the variance
covariance of this data ok and then I will use a few linear combination of these variables
we will try to figure out that ok.
So the essential component or the sort of this you know the thing that we will be using
is basically variance covariance data from the original data ok.
So we look at the variance along which line variance is maximum and so on so forth and
we simply do that.
Now one of the objectives of this approach is kind of you know reduce the correlated
features if I have three features and they are correlated then if one tells something
the other also is going to tell the similar thing third one is also going to tell the
similar thing then I do not need all three when one will do.
So the objective in this case is basically figure out which features are correlated and
I simply remove those correlated features keep only the one which will be enough for
me to decide my case.
So that is more or less the broad objective of this particular approach.
So the trick in this case is basically this.
Say we had this data for example you know do not look at this red lines but rather look
at this black lines for instance.
So X and on X was two dimensional data that I had and so on so forth.
Now clearly along the original axis X on and X to the data does not have the original the
maximum variability.
Now if you can rotate this axis little bit along the red lines then we see that along
the red lines we have the maximum variability.
So for example this red line have the PC1 along this line we have the maximum variability
in the data maximum variance you can see and then this red line is basically PC2 I calling
principal component to along which you have the next maximum amount of variance.
Now by nature PC1 and PC2 are perpendicular to each other that is the definition of this
one.
So therefore we have to figure out this red lines few red lines along which the variance
will be very high and then we will basically try to rotate the original axis along these
lines to figure out the new data transform data.
So what it does it takes a data matrix of n objects and p columns the n rows and p columns
p columns the p features we often call p variables.
And then the variables may be correlated often because that is basically one of the things
that we will try to do.
We summarize this entire thing by uncorrelated axis from correlated things to uncorrelated
axis we will try to do. And so the linear combination of this original p variables we try to figure
out using all this analysis that we are going to perform.
So the known fact in this case is that the fast k components of these new things that
we are going to discover will display as much as possible of the variation among the objects.
Our objective would be those fast k components or those fast k axis from the original data.
So what is the geometric rational or geometric intuition behind this PCA. So say the centroid
like the centroid of a point is defined by the mean of each variable that is like very
standard definition of this one. Now the variance of each variable is basically the average
squared with a variation of n values among the mean of these variables how far it is
from the centroid. That is basically the thing that we do.
So this is how basically we define the variance. We have the original data points which is
xim then we have the centroid and then simply compute the mean of that and so on so forth.
So then another important concept that we will use the covariance degree to which the
variables are linearly correlated to each other. So we define in this way. So this covariance
is basically computes to what extent two variables are related with each other.
So we simply do that xim and xjm. We basically simply compute the deviation from their mean
values and simply take the product and simply do that average. So these are two standard
definitions that we know variance and covariance and we will use this thing to figure out all
these axis and so on so forth. So the algebra of finding principle axis is basically we
can generalize this to p variables. So PC 1 principle component 1 is the direction
of the maximum variance, PC 2 is the next maximum variance, so on so forth, PC 3 is the next
maximum and so on so forth. So it is simply gradually increase. So if you can project
this data along PC 1, we will have the maximum variance then PC 2, next maximum variance
and so on so forth.
So we simply you know covariance, one thing that you have to do covariance is typically
covariance is basically you know unbounded in the sense that the values kind of like
very high value. So we simply normalize this entire thing by using normalization factors.
So what we do basically we divide this entire thing by standard deviation to make sure that
it lies between plus 1 and minus 1 so on so forth and which equal basically correlation.
So from covariance to correlation if you would like to go we simply divide this by variance
and so on so forth. So what is this algebra we do? So what do we do? We simply compute
the variance-covariance matrix which is nothing but square symmetric matrix. So diagonals
are the variances, off diagonals are the covariances something like that. So this is an example
of variance-covariance matrix that we have for two variables.
Then what we do? So in matrix notation if you deal with is nothing but X transpose X where
X is this matrix, you know 0 mean matrix and so on so forth. So we simply compute this
one. And then what it tells is basically some of the diagonals of the variance-covariance
matrix is called the trace. So it also tells you the total variance in the data. So in
this case the total variance is 12.909 or something like that. So then principal axis
involves the eigenvalues of the covariance matrix. So what we do? We figure out all the
eigenvalues for this particular covariance matrix, eigenvalue 1, eigenvalue 2, eigenvalue
and so on so forth. So we solve this equation to find out the eigenvalues lambda 1, lambda
2, lambda 3, so on. So in this case we get something like that, lambda 1 equals to 9.8,
lambda 2 equals to 3.03 and so on so forth. So lambda 3 is the highest eigenvalue, lambda
2 is the next highest eigenvalue and so on so forth.
So this will reflect the variance for a particular thing. Now we compute the eigenvectors for
each of these eigenvalues. Once you have the eigenvalues you can compute the eigenvectors.
Simply we can compute that. So the eigenvectors corresponding to the highest eigenvalue is
called the principal component. Next highest eigenvalue is the second principal component
and something like that. So it is simply, this way you simply proceed. So once we have
that the eigenvectors are basically the new axis that we have. First principal component
corresponding to the highest eigenvalue, second principal component corresponding to the second
highest eigenvalue and so on so forth.
So if you look at this figure carefully for example, this is my original data. Now I have
this first principal component that means the eigenvector corresponding to the highest
eigenvalue. I have the second principal component that means eigenvector corresponding to the
second highest eigenvalue and so on so forth. Now I have to shift, I have to transform my
original data along this axis. So how do I do that? For example, take a particular point.
So what do you do? This was my original value based on the original axis and so on so forth.
Now I have this new axis, I have this new axis and so on so forth. So now I have to project
this blue dot that did all the data points with respect to the new axis. So what do we
do? We do simply transformation something like this one. We compute this value and this
value. So therefore, the blue dot which was originally with respect to x1 and x2 now it
will be yi1 and yi2. So each data point therefore you can transform using these principal components
and simply use that for your purpose.
Now if you have say for example, 100 variables you would like to reduce to 10. So simply take
top 10 eigenvalues and the corresponding eigenvectors and simply project your data only with respect
to those eigenvectors. So that is the way you simply can actually project the high dimensional
data into low dimension. So that more or less gives the introduction to this unsupervised
learning. This is by no way complete. So clustering followed by principal component analysis.
So I will end with one small note. In today's world PCA is basically very principal approach.
It heavily relies on the linear relationship between objects. It uses the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors. But when you do not know the relationship between different things and so
on so forth different data points then the right thing to do is basically use something
which does not assume the linear relationship. So for example, autoencoder is a good approach
based on deep learning technologies which you possibly learn in one of the deep learning
lectures that people can make use of.
So with this I will end the session. So we have two questions and I will try to answer
these two questions. The first question is how K means plus plus is handling the outlays.
The example should have taken the earlier example with outlays. The reason that I basically
did not take the earlier example because in the earlier example I did not have any outlayer.
It had more or less the clean data. So that was the reason that I did not take it. But
to answer your main question how K means plus is handling the outlayer is something like
this. I must tell you that it is there is no guarantee that it will handle the outlayers.
K means plus plus is a probabilistic approach and the likelihood that it will handle outlayers
is basically high because this is selecting the points based on probability distribution
of the distances from the existing points ok.
So although mathematically it tells the points which are far apart from the existing points
will have higher chance, but there are other lot of points which will have slightly lesser
probabilities at this one ok. So as a result the those although these points will have higher
probability other points will also have slightly lower probability and there are many such
points. So as a result they can also select the points which are actually not outliers.
So I will I am not sure which probabilistic approach you are talking about whether this
is K means plus plus or this is the graph partitioning algorithm that you talked about.
So I am not very sure which probabilistic approach the student is asking for ok. So
maybe what I can do you please specify that one and I will maybe I will send a response
written response through the team on this particular thing ok.
So thank you very much and I will have another session on 5th of this next month 5th of April
and I will talk about transfer learning. So I will see you then ok. Thank you so much.